all is guarding Russell Westbrook
LeBron James
goes out down goes
he's high
he's pointing fingers LeBron trying oh
look at Ross
ouch
yeah he's got some uh
some blood wow running down his floor
here
or we did not see that blood until he
turned
[Applause]
thank you
that's not going to stop easily that
bleeding
[Applause]
99-92
[Applause]
you know the first one he took up when
he got the pass from LeBron he has
rejected but he stays right there with
it
then he makes a head fake and when
coming down
Collins hits him across the forehead
with the elbow and uh that's kind of
what upset Russia was under review for a
potential flagrant foul and as always
they look at the uh plays especially
when players jump up and go after
another player
and as a result of all the blood I would
assume they would call this a flagrant
one
[Applause]
where Russ Nui was hurt Russ took
exception to it
and it's about as hot as you're going to
see him get
LeBron immediately
intervening